let's bring in al jazeera's senior
political analyst now marwan bashara who
joins us by skype from paris marwan
thanks so much for being on the program
as we've been hearing there's this
almost feeling of anticipation that
things could escalate quickly
why haven't we seen hamas get involved
yet and will it
well actually this depends on what
happens the next day or two
what we've heard
earlier today from the israeli head of
intelligence
about the need for israel to wrap it up
as aware
because
there's a sense that if
the israel the israeli air force
continues to bombard gaza that hamas
will have
to get involved
and in that case then we are talking
about a wider
war
but if as it's claimed the israeli
forces have
accomplished as it were their mission by
killing more palestinian leaders
and terrorizing the gaza strip and they
will wrap it up
or start winding it down then we could
see an end to it
in few days uh with israel probably
taking credit for that
in terms of uh allowing the egyptians to
also take some credit for mediating a
so-called ceasefire so this is a very
sensitive moment now it could lead to
wider war or it could lead to wrapping
it up it's basically up to the israelis
at this point in time
as the head of the intelligence said for
them to wrap it up
yes speaking of the israelis where do
you think they sit with all of this have
they effectively made the point that
they wanted to make
well you know this is part of a
continuous
aggression against gaza
and every time it comes under different
pretext or justification
this time it is going after
al-jihad or as the israelis birth the
iranians supported islamic jihad in gaza
in a preemptive operation
to deter them from carrying terrorist
attack this is the israeli
pretext that's the israeli warding as it
were
of course it is part of a long pattern
and that pattern goes on not just a
decade or two it goes on over five
decades
for some of us who as you were emily
uh covering
the war in ukraine
it's been going on for five plus months
under similar pretext uh terror uh
preemption invasion punishment and of
course resistance to foreign occupation
and so on and so forth it's been going
on for five plus months and it angered
the entire world and and basically the
west the enlightened democracies are up
in arms about what's going on in ukraine
five plus months but in gaza this has
been going on for 50 plus
years
50 plus years of more of the same israel
using the same
pretext justification about combating
terror about
protecting its population while at the
same time occupying aggressing
terrorizing an entire people
so
in terms of this particular operation
they say they go they went after some
leaders of our assets of the islamic
jihad they terrorized gaza and the
process gaza that has over 50 percent
under the age of 16
50 percent of the population and we're
talking about a population that is an
absolute majority of refugees and their
descendants
so
terrorizing once again there's a certain
sadism to it all
so if israel thinks that
its sadistic mission is over with the
killing of so many and the terrorizing
of countless people well yes you could
say it is
this time around
all right well we certainly be watching
this space we appreciate your insights
as always marwan bashar al jazeera
senior political analyst thank you